[Music]
[Music]
okay my work ranges from wearable
sculpture to large-scale public art
installations and I'm now working in a
lab that designs from the micro to macro
scale using tools that nature
[Music]
my name is Nicolas kisi ke ulay I'm a
recent graduate of the ATT program so
that's art culture and it's basically
the visual arts program at MIT although
it's all about visual studies my
concentration or my focus has been over
the past three years and sound I try to
understand how sound affects the public
space and how public space is a space
for qualities to have a perspective in
this I make machines and these machines
and the thing my tools to to have a
voice in the construction of the sonic
soundscape hi son Brian Wong I'm a
senior majoring in computer science and
finance there's a industrial foul woven
dress that I made was inspired mostly by
a sense of a nebulous future and what
could be coming after undergraduate just
kind of where I am right now
I had my second show in the Sol LeWitt
room at MIT I featured the six looks for
women's wear looks at two men were looks
basically it was progression from
youthfulness into sort of unclear future
and adulthood
[Music]
my name is Gary's ex is an undergraduate
student in the first year of the art
culture technology program in my work
I'm predominantly a filmic and a writer
and the films I'm presenting here were
made over the past couple of years on a
number of different themes between
politics of identity and authenticity in
Chinese history but also on the
intersection of contemporary technology
and biology
[Music]
you